ننتقل الان خالد لابو ساميه وهو لحسن الحظ
لم يكن في المنزل حين انهار هذا المبنى
كان في المستشفى لتلقي العلاج هو يعاني من
اوضاع صحيه سيئه وبالتالي كان يعني بعيد
عن المنزل لكنه ايضا فقد بناته وزوجته
ممكن عمي ابو ساميه اول شيء عظم الله
اجركم والله يرحمهم ممكن تحكي لي من فقدت
انت في الزلزال انا يا امي خواتي تنتين
ابن اختي بنت اختي
زوجتي وبنات سنتين واخ الي
اعانك الله على هذا المصاب ابو ساميه في
انا عرفت انه عندك بنت ناجيه تحكي لي عن
وضعها وحكيت لي انه عندها وضع صحي معين
وهي بحاجه لعلاجات بحاجه تشرح لنا عن
وضعها وكم عمرها عمرها 16 سنه هي العمر 16
بس ما بحسب غير العقل
الها علاج الى اكل خاص كله العلاج يعني
الاكل الخاص كله غالي
طب بعد ما فقدته المنزل والبيت انت انا زي
ما فهمت ان انت كنت في المستشفى لمده 16
يوم لكن بعد ما فقدته المنزل الان انتم
وين موجودين نحن الان في بيت لكن هذا بيت
مين هذا البيت كان جاري زي ما كان ساكن
هون وهو اخ واب وعيلتنا العزيزه يعني
قعدنا عنده هلا نشوف شو يفرجها علينا
ان شاء الله شو ناقصكم عمي انتم يعني
كمتضررين
يعني انا بنتي هاي اني يعني
انا عيلتي بالاردن الي عيله واخواتي هنا
بالاردن اطلب من جهات المختصه بهالشغله
انه تحاول تساعدني تطلعني على الاردن مشان
بنتي
انت فقط كامل عائلتك هون فبالتالي انت خلص
يعني ما ضل لك اشي هون يعني زي ما بنحكيها
فيعني حاب تروح على الاردن عند اخوانك
المتبقين هناك كيف كان وضعهم كانوا يتصلوا
معك يتطمنوا عليك يحكوا معك كان يطمنوا
ويحكوا معي عادي اخ يعني
هلا حاب اني اتواصل اني الجهات اي جهات
تقدر تساعدنا نتواصل على الاردن انه نطلع
على الاردن
شكرا عمي ابو ساميه